so when you discovered your sexuality
let me ask about love
um
two pers far too personal of a question
to ask a brit but
um
what was that like and broadly speaking
what's the role of love in the human
condition
sex and love
and for you personally
discovering that you were and maybe
telling the world that you were
gay
i'm very perilously personal i do
actually have a sort of rule that i
don't talk about my personal life but uh
oh rules are meant to be broken okay
i'll break it a little bit um
the uh the the one of the ways in which
growing up and rising you're gay differs
from going off and being straight
is that it's almost inevitable that your
first passions will be unrequited
oh wow i never thought about that yeah
now that's not to say i mean you know
there's plenty of unrequited love among
young men for young women young women of
young men plenty of yeah you know that
but it's almost inevitable if you're gay
that your first
uh
you know
passions will be totally unrequited
because the odds are
that the person in question will not be
gay so the experience of love is mostly
heartbreak it's heartbreak
and disappointment that heartbreak can
be beautiful too of course
well as again it comes back to the thing
if you're a writer or something because
you can always do something with it
that's why all writers are sort of not
to be trusted
i i i didn't trust you the moment you
walked in here
no i mean it's a famous problem with the
writers because you always think i could
use dangerous it's a dangerous thing and
all right it's almost like a drug right
uh no it's it's not like a drug it's
it's uh the fear that all
things even the greatest suffering um it
could be material
what's that what's the danger in that
exactly that seeing the material in the
human experience you don't experience it
fully you don't experience it fully and
you might be using it
i had a friend who wrote a poem about a
friend who died in a motorcycle accident
in sydney in the 60s
and he said he knew the moment he was
told that his friend's death a tiny bit
of him thought i could use this for poem
and he did and the poem was wonderful
but there's always that slight guilt for
writers of
am i going to use that anyhow that's a
divergence
life is full of guilty pleasures and i
think that's one of them because if you
feel that guilt
really what you're doing is you're
capturing that moment and you're going
to impact the lives of many many people
by writing about that moment because
it's going to stimulate something that
resonates with those people because they
had similar kinds of memories about a
yes and a passion towards somebody that
they had to lose so don't you know yes
but there is a good sign perhaps
more obvious perhaps problem is um
reporting from war zones or bad places
and wanting to find bad stories because
it's useful and there's there is a
definite guilt you get from that sort of
thing like the worse the situation the
more useful and anyhow
um
no so that's that's sort of the only
difference that happens from growing up
being gay and it means that
most
certainly in my generation most gay men
[Music]
came to
sexual or romantic maturity later
and there's lots of explanations of that
um maybe being one of the reasons for
perceived or otherwise promiscuity among
gay men
which is i think more easily persuaded
by the fact that gay men behave like
men would if women were men
that's that's one explanation but it it
it's both a feature and a bug that you
come to
sexual flourishing later in life that
could be seen as a yeah
in the trajectory of human life that
could be a positive or a negative yeah
but what's broadly speaking is the role
of love in the human condition douglas
well it's the nearest thing we have to
finding the point
what what is the point what's what's the
meaning of life let's go there so what's
the meaning is a hard one of course
where is the meaning is slightly easier
and i'd say that everyone can find that
um you gravitate towards the places you
find meaning
now there's a conservative answer to
this which is quite useful and it's
certainly more useful than any others
because the conservative answer is find
meaning where people have found it
before
which is a very very good answer yeah
if if your ancestors have found meaning
in a place of worship or a particular
canon of work
go there because it's been proven by
time
to be able to give you the girds
um
much more sensible than saying hey i
don't know discover new ways of meaning
um
uh but
love is
um
love is probably the nearest thing we
can have
to the divine
um on earth and of course the problem of
what exactly
what type of love we mean is a
is an issue
well that goes to the fact that you
don't like uh definitions anyway i do
like definitions i just say they need to
be pinned down
but let's not
let's not go there at
the moment because it's
does not pin down love at the moment
well
no because as you know i mean because of
the different varieties of love and the
fact that we have one word for it in our
culture and that it means an awful lot
of things and we don't delineate it yeah
well but
let's say human love
with the greatest fulfillment in um uh
sexual
fulfillment in sexual love with another
person
is um
probably the greatest intimation you can
have of
what um
might otherwise only be superseded by
divine love
um
and it's the
um
the sense that all young lovers have
which is that
they've just
walked through the low door in the
garden and found themselves in bliss
and that this is
there's a beautiful beautiful poem of
can i read it to you yes please
um i'll try to find there's a beautiful
poem of philip larkins
which slightly says
what i'm
i'm i'm trying not to dock your question
by referring to other people but maybe
that's the best way to answer the
question could bit is to read we read a
poem
so there's a poem by um philip larkin
called high windows
which is um
which is remarkable because
he he
um became sexual he was straight he he
and had a rather unhappy sex life but he
um
uh
came to sexual first in the 40s and 15
with all the hell that involved
and um
he took us he took what i remember
regarding being a really remarkable and
important view on the sexual revolution
in the 60s which is that most people
whose generation older people resented
the young
they resented the freedom they had and
actually they pretended the freedom was
terrible and it was always getting
likely to and larkin rather surprisingly
a very conservative person took a
different view and he says it in this
poem and the opening of a poem is he
says
when i see a couple of kids and guess
he's [ __ ] her and she's taking pills
or wearing a diaphragm i know this is
paradise everyone old has dreamed of all
their lives
bonds and gestures pushed to one side
like an outdated combine harvester and
everyone young going down the long slide
to happiness endlessly
i wonder if anyone looked at me 40 years
back and thought
that'll be the life no god anymore or
sweating in the dark about hell and that
or having to hide what you think of the
priest he and his lot will all go down
the long slide like free bloody birds
and immediately
rather than words comes the thought of
high windows
the sun comprehending glass
and beyond it the deep blue air
that shows nothing and is nowhere
and is endless
the divine
he found it
he found it in seeing a couple of young
kids
and knowing that one of them was wearing
a diaphragm
do you see it i mean it's first of all
it's very counterintuitive but secondly
this is the point that
sex had been so
tied up with misery
i mean people don't remember this now
when they talk about
the past i mean that's one of my
favorite books stefan's likes the world
of yesterday including the descriptions
of what it was like
trying to have sex in pre-first world
war vienna you know all the men ended up
going to female prostitutes you know so
many of them got syphilis and this was
their first experience of sex it was so
goddamn awful and they were stuck with
it all their lives i know
so there's lots of stuff that's gone
better in our ascension that's one of
them
but you ask about love yes i do think
that love is basically um um
uh
the thing that gives us the best glimpse
of the divine
and by the way sex
liberating sex
doesn't buy you
um
love no i mean it throws in an entirely
it
it threw in another set of problems
um if if there's any meaning on top of
all that is we like to
find problems and solve that as a human
species and sometimes we even create
problems
um
douglas thank you for highlighting all
the problems of human civilization and
giving us a glimmer of hope for the
future this is an incredible
conversation thank you for talking today
it's a huge honor thank you it's very
kind of you say that thank you
you